تساقط كثيف للثلوج في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف في الوقت الذي مازال 25 بالمئه من
سكان المدينه دون كهرباء وتعمل سلطات
المدينه لاستعاده التيار واستقرار جدول
القطع الكهربائي على ان لا يتجاوز عدد
ساعات الانقطاع خمس ساعات في اليوم همم
وسنستعيد جولي بولو محافظه تاريخ
وكل شيء سيكون بخير فهذه اوكرانيا
باي حال من الاحوال سوف نتعامل مع كل
الظروف ولن ننكسر
يعملون بالفعل على ازاله الثلوج من
الطرقات في الوقت الحالي تعمل مئه وسته
وعشرون وحده من المعدات واكثر من 300
متخصصه من هيئه الصيانه الطرق ويشاركه في
الحمله اكثر من 1,000 عام من الشركات
المتعاقده مع الدوله
انا اعمل عليه ازاله الثلوج الثلج يتساقط
بطبيعه الحال في هذا التوقيت ونحن نعمل
على ازالتها ونظافه الشوارع
وفقا للتوقعات ستزداد كثافه تساقط الثلوج
والصقيع في المدينه كما ستنخفض درجه
الحراره الى درجتين مئتين تنصف خلال
النهار وسالب 50 درجات مئويه في الليل
لذلك تحث السلطات المواطنين على الامتناع
عن السفر في سيارته الخاصه كما يطلب من
السائقين توخي الحذر على الطريق واذا امكن
عدم قياده السياره اثناء تساقط الثلوج اذا
فعادل العربيه كيف